how you doing Steve how are you you know
when we were both asked to do this
obviously was an honor for both of us to
get invited it's such a good cause too
for people to give to families who need
but I was so excited when when I heard
that you wanted to do this with me I'm a
fan I'm a big fan especially after
reading this book right here
you're very kind this is an incredible
book it uh it helped for me it helped me
identify my why and that was really
important because you I mean I like I I
don't want to get too ahead of it
because like it's not just a
conversation feeding us too but it's
about conversation with everyone else
but Wow that book is inspirational it it
really touched me and it's it's not just
for people that have businesses or have
brands but it can apply to everybody
Steve I'm I'm grateful you know one of
the things that I so appreciate about
your work and I think you and I are
kindred spirits in the sense because
when it was announced that you and I I'd
be doing this together I think a lot of
people were scratching their heads you
know and and I think the thing that you
and I have in common is we we spread
optimism you know the thing that we do
is we share hope with everybody and and
I'm it doesn't surprise me that the
concept of why resonates with you it is
the foundation for who we are when we're
at our natural best it is the foundation
for inspiration and never was there a
time more like now than to reconnect
with our foundation with who we are it
certainly helped me through these times
and I'm and and and I've been trying to
share it with as many people as possible
for that same reasons yeah I mean one of
the most common questions people ask me
when I'm doing interviews with whoever
is how do you find inspiration and yeah
it's just like you're saying it's it's
so important to to find that inspiration
be inspired feel that the agency or
empowerment to you know take action
in your life whatever it might be yeah
actually when we're stuck in our home is
isolated we need that that's the time
when we need to take I mean what what I
think Tony Robbins calls massive action
you know like when you feel down you got
you have to take action you know and for
me the the thing that's been helping
getting me through this and I know has
been helping my friends get to this is
is that we are going through this
together our experiences are not exactly
the same but we're all going we're all
going through this together and the
biggest thing that I've learned
throughout all this is to ask for help
some of us are ashamed to ask for help
embarrassed ask for help fear hearing
the word know or getting disappointed
but at the end of the day human beings
were just not that strong by ourselves
we're not that smart by ourselves but in
groups and tribes together we're
remarkable and and we're surrounded by
people who want to help in fact we build
trust by helping each other we don't
build trust by by offering our help to
others we build trust by asking for it
it's that it's the willingness to to put
ourselves out there and it's it's the
greatest honor to be of service you know
we are animals built of service so it's
and and here we are both being called to
service to do our part to to answer the
call to unite yeah for me when I'm at
home and I'm bored and I'm I'm flipping
on my I'm going through my phone
scrolling through different lives or
going on YouTube ooh check out different
live streams and I see conversations
being had
it's like those conversations and the
communication it's constantly happening
online it inspires me like oh I could
actually converse a or communicate with
someone else
and I know I was inspired by by some
sort of conversation that I'm watching
that like I'm thinking back to myself
like what can I do to spread a message
that can help deal with mental health
during COBIT or deal with boredom or
deal with whatever it might be that
we're all dealing with because we're all
stuck at home it doesn't matter if
you're an entertainer if you're a
speaker or if
or you know just anyone and you know
whatever it is we're all we're all at
home so it's I think it's important that
like hey we can all have this completely
this conversation anyone can have this
conversation Chris Pratt
Chris Pratt said it really well when
when when when people talked about how
you know we're all at home he said it's
not quite true you know he says you know
it's not like we're all in the same boat
together he said some people's boats are
more dope than others he said he said so
it's it's it's ridiculous for for for
celebrities to say you know we're going
we're all in the same boat together but
what he did say which I loved is but
we're all in the same ocean yeah and and
we're all we're all going through this
together we're all we're all suffering
the storm together and that is true and
you know what I find remarkable about
this is is it's for the it's the first
time definitely in my my lifetime if not
all of our lifetimes where we can relate
to somebody on the other side of the
planet people who you know who are
different than us who we we will never
have a probably a chance to meet and now
there's the shared common human
experience and nothing brings people
together then then shared hardship and
shared experience it's this is a really
special moment and yes we're in a dark
tunnel but there is a light at the end
of the tunnel we will get through this I
don't know how far away the light is but
we will get through it and the question
is what can we learn how do we get
through this tunnel so we're we're we're
better versions of ourselves than when
we went in absolutely absolutely and I
guess that's what I'm learning to you
know like I think all of us are like
picking up new skill sets while we're at
home you know well you started playing
chess right yeah yeah I mean while we're
waiting in the in our the virtual green
room playing a little chess I'm Nessen
that's a new hobby just picking up it's
well I'm super impressed because I had a
list of books I was gonna read and list
of skills I was gonna get and you know I
had my workout schedule and you know I
have no boxes checked off all the books
are still there all the skills are still
an unlearned and my work I'm not as buff
and I thought I was going to come out of
this so it's funny it's funny how we
respond to all of this empty space yeah
we have like a high goals you know I
mean
we come into this with this like okay
we've got a lot of time on our hands
let's learn a language let's uh work out
more let's do all these things but I
mean it's hard it's like hard to put
that into practice in theory you get
excited right excited about I think the
demographic for tick-tock has gone up
though I think we're now making
tick-tock videos it's not just for kids
anymore I want to see some I want to see
simon Sinek doing a little tick tock
challenge dance though there is one of
the dances that my niece is she and I
are determined to do together
she's much quicker at learning these
dances than I am
we'll see we'll see yeah you like you
can't like lock as well you know you
can't you know you start like losing the
the reflex or like the you know the
swagger or something yeah I have one
question for you can you tell me a
specific story of something throughout
your career
that you absolutely love being a part of
that that for all of the the strain and
the stress and and that goes with the
job
that that there's this one example of
something that just was magical for you
I mean I think it's being on stage
that's like a very simple answer but a
generic is like a general answer but
being with the audience being with the
crowd like there's no doubt if I have an
addiction to something it's it's with
performing to to people i I do 250 shows
on average every single year and I
haven't stopped for 15 years I had I
haven't I haven't I've been more on the
road than been at home for 15 years of
my life consistently so there's no doubt
that like it's not just my management
pushing it's like I want to be on the
road I love the owner even all the the
you know the jet lag you have to deal
with or the airport whatever he had to
deal with by flying around so much it's
worth it for that that 90 minutes in
front of different people different
crowds and and there's so much to cover
you know you realize like you know you
have there's so many different country
so many different cities and luckily for
me
my music electronic music that I that I
produce and I play is global there's
it's a language of music is its own
language and it this is this very
powerful language this is I think the
perfect sum up for why we're doing this
which is though we're we're not
physically together as a population
anymore we are still together United in
spirit United to do good for each other
we're taking part in things like this
and we're doing this for the good of
others this is a call to service and so
both Steve and I were grateful to the
call to unite that we could be a part of
it but most important we're asking
everybody else to give what you can
share what you can to those who need it
more
Steve's such a pleasure so good to meet
you
and I hope we get to do this again soon
IRL definitely
[Music]